FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
101 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague, Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I am good.
I am hanging out in my parents'
house in Melbourne, Australia.
So it's really nice being back--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: --in my home.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Very good, very good.
And I am here hanging out in
my home here in San Francisco.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, and very excited
about a really cool episode.
We've talked about IoT
Core a couple times,
but we had not done
an episode yet.
So we got two people, one
from the IoT Core team
itself, Indranil Chakraborty.
But also we got
Gabe Weiss, which
is a developer advocate
in our team for Cloud
that works specifically
with IoT and IoT Core.
So really, really
excited about that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
And then after that we'll
have our question of the week.
It's all about Francesc.
He wrote a really
interesting podcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: And so we're
going to talk about it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It is about
me, as it should always be.
[LAUGHTER]
But before that we have our
cool things of the week.
And there's three of them.
The first one I'm going to say
it because it is really, really
exciting.
We finally got Go 1.8 on app
engine standard environment,
which is awesome.
And it is now
generally available.
It had been a beta
for a little bit,
now it is already the
default, which is awesome.
If you have never
used it, do not
worry because it's, as
always, backwards compatible.
So if you build
something with Go 1.5
it will still work with Go 1.8.
But there's new things
in Go 1.8 such as--
well, context was
in Go 1.6, Go 1.7,
but there's many,
many, many new things
that happened since then
that might make you happy
and a happier gopher.
So check it out.
Also, everything is
faster, as usual with Go.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
always faster.
The second cool thing of the
week is basically all about us
because we are the
most important.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
As it should be.
MARK MANDEL: As it should be.
So we wrote a blog post
celebrating the fact
that we hit 100 episodes.
You may have noticed we
interviewed Vint Cerf.
We may have got a
little excited about it,
and maybe my voice went up--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We did notice.
MARK MANDEL: --three octaves
when I got excited about it.
[LAUGHTER]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh my God!
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I
did get very excited.
So we wrote a blog
post about it.
And in that blog post
we basically also list
the 10 most popular
episodes that have been
downloaded from the podcast.
And there's some
good ones in there.
Some of my favorites, Container
Engine with Chen Goldberg,
Kubernetes 1.7 with Tim Hockin.
Office of CTO with Greg.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, Cloud Spanner.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cloud Spanner
with Deepti Srivastava.
That was amazing.
MARK MANDEL: That was amazing.
Yeah, so they're all good.
So if you're maybe not as
familiar with our stuff
and you're just getting
started with the podcast,
you might want to go
back and have a look.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And the
last cool thing of the week
is something that is really,
really cool, especially
for those that do not know
Google Cloud Platform that
well, and they get
confused between what
is Cloud Datalab and
Dataprep, and this studio,
and all of these things.
There's a list done by our
dear manager, Greg Wilson.
He wrote a really cool cheat
sheet I want to call it.
Because you have basically
for every single product
a description in
four words or less.
And I agree with most of them.
Some of them are
kind of cheating
because what he does
is, he uses the words
that the product stands for.
I mean, if you say IoT
and you describe it
as Internet of Things, I call
that not describing much.
But other than that it's
actually really good.
MARK MANDEL: No,
it is really good.
So, for example, like Cloud
IM is resource access control.
Virtual Private Cloud is like
software-defined networking.
He cheats a bit with hyphens.
So Cloud Functions is event
driven serverless applications.
But no, it totally is good.
And it's also really nice
in that not only does it
do four word
descriptions, it also
shows the free tiers for
each of the products as well.
So if you're like,
what is this thing,
and also, what can
I get for free,
it has a column there that
shows those for all the products
that have free tiers,
which is also really nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I think
it'd be an awesome thing
to give to people
at conferences,
or even to print it
as something that you
can have in your office if
you're using Google Cloud
Platform a lot.
It may help you in
conversation with coworkers.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I think it's going
to help me, actually.
I'm going to read through it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: There's
actually a very high res image
that you can definitely print
into something quite big.
It can be a fun thing to have.
MARK MANDEL: Put on the
wall in your office.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Or not.
MARK MANDEL: Oh my God, yes.
I kind of want to do that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep.
[LAUGHS]
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
All right, well why don't we
go talk to Gabe and Indranil
and chat all about
Cloud IoT Core?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
am very excited today
to welcome two more
people to our podcast
to talk about IoT Core.
And nonetheless, we got
Indranil Chakraborty,
a product manager for IoT Core.
Hello, Indranil.
How are you doing?
INDRANIL CHAKRABORTY:
Hi, Francesc.
I'm doing fine.
Thanks for having me here today.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank
you for joining us.
And we also have Gabe Weiss.
And he's a fellow
developer advocate
at Google Cloud
Platform, working also
for IoT Core and IoT stuffs.
How are you doing?
GABE WEISS: I'm doing well.
How about you?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Doing great.
Very excited.
We're going to be
talking about IoT Core.
We've mentioned it a couple
times during the podcast,
but mostly as a cool
thing of the week,
and really quick without
getting too much into detail.
So today we're going
to have the opportunity
to talk a lot about it.
But before that, why don't
we start a little bit
by telling us who you are and
what you do here at Google?
We can start with you, Indranil.
INDRANIL CHAKRABORTY: Great.
So I'm Indranil Chakraborty,
and I'm the product manager
for Google Cloud IoT Core.
And my job really is to set the
overall strategy and the vision
for the product, work
with customers closely,
understand what the needs are.
And then work with
engineering so
that we can build the right
product which will add value
to our customers.
So my job, really, is to work
with customers, engineering,
devrel, marketing, and
other cross-functional team
so that we're building the
right product for the customers.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
What about you, Gabe?
GABE WEISS: So I'm the developer
advocate for Google Cloud
Platform, kind of
focusing on not just
IoT Core but the IoT platform.
So I'm really serving
the developers
that are using the
devices out in the world,
the connected devices, to
do bigger, better things.
So IoT Core specifically is the
entryway into the rest of GCP.
So I'm here to make sure that
the product that Indranil's
building with the
cross teams really
does land with
developers, and make sure
that it's successful
with them and that they
can use it to do their things.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
All right.
So Indranil, you're
the PM, so I'm going
to ask you the hard question.
So 30,000 foot view,
what is IoT Core
from a really basic standpoint?
INDRANIL CHAKRABORTY: Sure.
So if you look at
Google Cloud Platform,
we have what we believe
is a state of the art,
well-received data analytics
and machine learning services
today, available
for our enterprise
customers, our developers,
and our partners as well.
And what Cloud IoT
Core does is, it really
makes it easy to onboard
your IoT devices, things that
are in your factory, in
your oil and gas rigs
or other enterprise
setting to easily
onboard those devices
to Google Cloud
so that you can start pushing
data from your devices
to Google Cloud,
and start benefiting
from our data analytics and
machine learning services.
So that's essentially
what Cloud IoT Core does.
It is a fully-managed service
to securely connect and manage
your IoT devices on
Google Cloud platform.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So when you say to securely
connect, what I'm expecting
is there's some secure way to
even start the communication.
How do you make sure that those
devices are those devices?
Do you expect the unit to
install certificates in them?
What do you mean by
securely communicate?
INDRANIL CHAKRABORTY:
Yeah, so we deeply
care about security
for the devices
as well as the data that
is being transmitted
from the device to Cloud.
So first, as you
mentioned Francesc,
it's really about
secure connection
of the device to the Cloud.
So IoT Core supports asymetric
key based authentication
in each individual device.
So what that means is, you
will have a private key which
you store securely-- which
it will store in the device,
and then you would
register a public key
from the device based on the
private key onto Cloud IoT Core
so when the device makes a
connection to Cloud IoT Core,
we can verify based on the
signature of the device
that it sends with
the public key
to make sure that that device
is really what it says it is.
And we use standard JWT
token for authentication
between the device and IoT Core.
So the device will
use the private key
to sign a JWT token, and then
it will send the JWT token
to IoT Core, and then we use
the JWT token to then verify
the signature with our public
key that has been registered.
So that's one aspect, where
we authenticate each device
at an individual level.
And second is, even
for a connection
we support TLS 1.2 and above.
So we expect that each
device will use TLS 1.2
to make the initial
connection to Google Cloud IoT
Core over TCP.
Anything outside, if it's not
TLS, we reject that connection.
That's the first step.
And then further as that data
gets transmitted to Cloud IoT
Core, whether it's
at rest in the Cloud
or whether it's in
transit, the data
is always in encrypted form.
So that's the way we ensure
security at the device level
during connection as well as
at the data level as well.
MARK MANDEL: And also
for the TLS connection
on the other end,
the device will also
need to have a root
certificate on it
to verify on the other side that
the device knows it's actually
talking to Google.
So you can either use
Google provided root cert,
or when you create your bucket
in GCP for your devices--
we call it the registry.
When you create
your registry, you
can specify a third
party root certificate
if you want to use
something else.
So that's the
other on the device
side to make sure it knows
it's talking to Google.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
I have a bunch of
questions, but the first one
is, you said JWT
token many times.
Is that J-W-T?
INDRANIL CHAKRABORTY: Yes.
It is JWT.
It's essentially JSON Web Token.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK, cool.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
All right, so you covered
the security side of it.
What's the communication
part of it?
What does that actually mean?
Are they just sending faxes
to each other or something?
Or what's the deal?
GABE WEISS: Smoke signal.
It's all smoke signal.
INDRANIL CHAKRABORTY: [LAUGHS]
So as part of Cloud IoT Core,
we realized that MQTT
is a protocol which
is pretty standard
in the industry.
And so we started with a
native support for MQTT
on Cloud IoT Core.
So now with MQTT, devices
can publish telemetry, even
other information on
MQTT topic to IoT Core.
And IoT Core then
aggregates all the data
across all the devices,
and then pushes
it downstream to
Pub/Sub topic from where
you can consume,
and then send it
downstream to other services
such as BigQuery or BigTable
and as such.
So really, the
transmission between device
and communication between
device and IoT Core
will depend on the protocols.
If you use MQTT, then you
can publish your telemetry
on a certain topic and
then we take it from there.
If you're using HTTP, we
also have support for HTTP,
as you know.
If you use HTTP, then you would
do a request-response protocol
to send your data and
telemetry to Cloud IoT Core.
MARK MANDEL: And MQTT, is
that a bidirectional protocol,
or is it just sending data
from the device down to Cloud?
INDRANIL CHAKRABORTY: I'm
glad you brought it up.
Yes, MQTT is a
bidirectional protocol.
It is based on TCP.
And the way it works is,
your devices will publish
certain data to a
particular topic,
and Cloud can also published
data to a certain topic
for the device to subscribe
to and get the data.
So it is bidirectional.
And IoT Core supports
bidirectional data
between the device and
the Cloud over MQTT.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Now
that we're in the center
of the debate what
this product does
and the security
part of it, I am
curious about what is the
audience of this product?
Meaning if I'm building, I
don't know, smart lightbulbs,
is this for me?
Or if it's I'm
building something
like a home hack where
I have something like I
have just one little device--
I'm actually trying to
work on this, by the way.
[LAUGHTER]
Something that allows me to open
the garage door from my phone.
What is-- who is this for?
INDRANIL CHAKRABORTY: Yeah,
so Cloud IoT Core is really
built for scale, right?
So if you think about
an enterprise company
or a smart parking company,
they have thousands and hundreds
of thousands of devices
installed in different parking
lots and on the curbside.
And all of these
devices and sensors
are sending data
pretty frequently.
So they've been able to connect
all those devices to Cloud IoT
Core and ingest
the data at-scale.
So IoT Core is really
designed to connect
massive amount of devices and
just a massive scale of data
without a customer
or the partner, even
the developer needing to
worry about the infrastructure
and provisioning.
You just connect your devices.
Whether you're connecting
one or millions
of devices or even billions,
we will scale internally.
We will be able to ingest data
at-scale without an issue.
So that's what is really
designed and built for.
Now having said
that, we understand
that in a lot of
developers enterprise,
and even the
commercial developers,
they wanted to get
their hands dirty,
they want to build
some quick prototype
before they deploy at-scale.
So we made it easy and simple
enough for even the developers
who wants to jumpstart
their journey on IoT to be
able to quickly build some
prototype using IoT Core.
So we do have a
rich set of APIs.
At the same time, we have a
pretty simple user interface
for any developer, or even
an operator for that matter,
to quickly build
some quick prototype
to test out the product
before they scale.
So really, going back
to your question,
it is designed for scale.
But at the same time, we expect
a wide spectrum of customers
and developers to use it.
Developers who are building
it for a massive scale
and for an enterprise
grade product.
At the same time, developers who
want to get their hands dirty,
they want to build
some quick prototype
before they graduate
to the next level
where they deploy
full scale devices.
GABE WEISS: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So, Gabe, I'm going
to direct this
to you because I know
you've been building stuff
with IoT Core.
What does the development
experience look like?
GABE WEISS: I'm
pretty new to Google.
I just started in May.
So one of the hardest
ramp ups I've had
is learning all the different
pieces of GCP, learning all
the APIs, how to build stuff.
IoT Core is by far the easiest
I've worked with so far,
hands down.
It's a managed service.
So you don't have to
stand anything up,
you don't have to start a GCE,
you don't have to do anything.
It's an end point.
So what that means is, I'm
free to sit on my device,
and I implement the three pieces
that I need to worry about.
I need to worry about
the JWT authentication.
initializing the communication
piece.
And then I need my sensor
data, my telemetry,
whatever that ends up being.
And that's it.
I don't have to download
any SDKs from Google Cloud,
I don't have to implement
any funky Cloud stuff.
I can just put this message
together in MQTT, publish it,
and Google handles
the rest of it.
And I end up with data in
my Cloud Pub/Sub topic.
So from a development
standpoint,
I have to pick my
library of choice.
I've worked with
Python, Note.js,
there's some C libraries that
work with just bare metal.
I just did this
last week when I was
at the conference in Barcelona.
It was a 10 minute theater
talk where it was bare
device, nothing on it.
And at the end of 10 minutes,
you have your messages in Cloud
that you can do stuff with.
So it's super easy.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And you didn't have
to install anything
specific for IoT Core?
I'm assuming you're just putting
in some sort of MQTT client
on the device that's very
standard that you don't
have to worry about otherwise?
GABE WEISS: Yeah, so
there's standard--
that's the three
languages I mentioned.
So they're just standard
libraries for each one.
Paho MQTT is the
kind of de facto MQTT
library across all of them.
JWT, there's a PyJWT for Python.
It's one that I was using.
So those are the only things you
need to install on the device.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And I suppose
then also that means then
that you're not tied to
a particular hardware
provider or a particular
set of IoT device,
you can basically
run this on anything.
GABE WEISS: On
pretty much anything
that can talk to the internet.
So we've done everything
from the lowest
level, the microcontrollers.
The ESP8266 are these little
nice Wi-Fi controllers
that are super slim, don't
do anything other than Wi-Fi.
And we've got it to work on
those through Arduino, Pi,
and then on some
of the industrial.
We've worked with a couple
of partners and their devices
to get those talking
to Core also.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
So I'm curious about the
developing experience.
You're saying that you have
basically a Pub/Sub queue
and that you're receiving
all the messages from there,
which seems relatively easy.
I'm imagining that when you
receive that, in the payload
there's some
identification of what
is the origin, what
is the device exactly
that is sending the data?
GABE WEISS: You
don't necessarily
unless you put it in there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, OK.
GABE WEISS: You have
a record of the device
as it's registered
in the system,
and there's some ID in there,
but there wouldn't be any way
to tie a Pub/Sub message
back to your device
necessarily unless you
added it to the payload.
Which is best practice,
we recommend of course
that you do that.
But the bridge in IoT
Core, it's a pass-through.
So as the messages
come into IoT Core,
it bundles it up
with some metadata.
Indranil, correct
me if I'm wrong,
but I don't think it actually
identifies the device.
INDRANIL CHAKRABORTY:
We do have--
so Pub/Sup has this notion
of a message attributes,
I think as you guys know.
So as part of
message attribute, we
do put the device ID as part
of the message attribute.
So when you're
consuming the data
as a subscriber from
Pub/Sub, every message
you get you can
read the message.
After which then you can
use that to know that
this particular
message has been sent
by the thermostat
in your living room
versus the thermostat in
your bedroom, for example.
So the Pub/Sub
message attribute,
which is where we
add the device ID.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
So once you have that ID,
how do you reply to it?
What if you want to send a
message to a specific device?
INDRANIL CHAKRABORTY:
So there's two things.
So one is, for
every time a device
publishes a message,
a telemetry,
could be a temperature
measurement
or could be a pressure
measurement to Cloud IoT Core,
if IoT Core then could bridge.
If it's able to publish
that message successfully
to Pub/Sub, it will send
an ACK back to the device.
So the device that we know that
the message that it had sent,
the measurement, that data
that it has sent to IoT Core
has been received
and acknowledged.
That's one way of communication.
Then the next is,
as a developer you
may want to send some message
back to the device, right,
or some communication,
some control command
back to the device,
or some configuration
update back to the device.
So we have-- part
of IoT Core, there
are APIs which will allow you
to directly send a message
to a specific device ID.
So you can say, I want
to change the temperature
setting of the thermostat
in the living room.
You can specify the device
ID of the thermostat
and send a specific
configuration change
to the device.
And the good thing
about IoT Core
is, with IoT, the connectivity
is sort of intermittent.
Most of the time it's
there, but sometimes
because of bandwidth constraint
or because of your location
or whatnot, it's not always
continuously connected.
So IoT Core makes sure that
when you send the latest
configuration, when the
device-- if the device
is not connected, when
the device comes back up
and connects, it will send
the latest configuration
to the device.
So from an application
perspective,
you build your
application and you're not
worried about the upstream
connection and the data flow
between the Cloud and device.
IoT Core takes care of it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: So serverless
is the cool new buzzword.
[LAUGHTER]
So it's going to be serverless
or ML, one or other.
I'm looking at diagrams here
on the Cloud IoT Core website,
and I see that there's a way
to hook in Cloud Functions.
Or is Cloud Functions
just really useful here?
Where does that fit in?
GABE WEISS: Cloud Functions
is just super useful.
Because with Cloud
Functions, you
have the hook for Pub/Sub
message getting subscribed.
So since IoT Core connects
directly into Pub/Sub,
so everything you publish to
IoT Core goes into Pub/Sub,
your Cloud Functions
now can hook into that
and do stuff based on
whatever you want it to.
So you can route
things to-- you can
use Cloud Functions to route the
data from Pub/Sub to anywhere
you want.
Store it in a database, send
it along to BigQuery or machine
learning.
All of the stuff that
might be overkill for some
of the other systems,
GCP, Cloud Function
is just a super
nice, lightweight way
to do some of that stuff.
INDRANIL CHAKRABORTY: Yeah.
In fact, if you think
about a simple use case
where you're reading
the temperature setting
from your thermostat, or then
you're consuming it to Pub/Sub,
you can have a
Cloud Function which
reads the temperature setting.
And when it goes
above 80 degrees,
it can send a message back to
the same thermostat to say,
turn off the air condition.
So there's a Cloud
Function in conjunction
with, like Gabe mentioned
with Pub/Sub topic,
can really be used to build
a very simple business
logic with IoT Core.
So I think that's one area
where we do see developers
trying out and building simple
rules and business logics.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I just thought about
if this then that.
That's basically
what you're saying.
You're able to build a
system that is basically
just events and Cloud Functions
as the glue connecting them.
GABE WEISS: Yeah, and
stay completely serverless
in that fashion.
So you don't have to have
any of these functions living
somewhere, they just
live in the Cloud.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's cool.
Since you were
mentioning use cases,
is there any other use case
that you've seen lately
that was really
exciting, or something
that you didn't expect when you
were designing this product?
INDRANIL CHAKRABORTY: When
we design the product,
we always had sort of commercial
and enterprise segment in mind.
And even we didn't-- in
this segment there's been--
I was personally pretty amazed
by some of the applications
and use case which customers and
partners have been using for.
So one example is
around ride sharing.
And this is something
which is picking
up a lot in UK and Asia, so the
whole notion of bike sharing
in cities.
And we've seen a couple of
our partners and customers
using it so that their bikes
are connected to Cloud IoT Core.
And they have a mobile
app so the user,
as it gets closer to the bike
they have been assigned to,
it automatically unlocks.
And so you can take the
bike and start using it.
So that is a pretty
interesting application which
we're seeing using IoT Core.
I talked about smart parking.
That's another area where--
we have a reference
customer who's
been using this for
notify the drivers
about the specific
particular parking
lot that is open and
available in real time.
But also as they
collect data, they're
also using it to provide
more traffic information
to the city, to, for example,
Auckland Transport in Sydney.
City So we're seeing use case
from ride sharing to providing
some real time information.
And then as they
collect this data,
we've also seen use cases where
they use the data to provide
more advanced analytics
around traffic management,
or even in some cases,
predictive maintenance
is another area
where we're seeing
a lot of these use cases in
manufacturing particularly.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
This reminds me a
lot of this interview
that we're preparing for
next week with smart parking
where they talk
about how they're
using all of these technologies,
and on Google Cloud with Cloud
Functions, obviously, to
basically make parking smarter.
It's very, very exciting.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Gabe, have you seen
anything else that's
particularly interesting?
GABE WEISS: There's
a lot of stuff.
I was talking to
one of the partners
last week about using
IoT telemetry data off
of drones to map really
hard to reach places,
and then using the
GPS and altitude
data off of the devices
to help create maps.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
GABE WEISS: It was really cool.
MARK MANDEL: So
plans for the future.
It's probably-- I know the
correct answer is always,
we can't speak about road
maps, but I have to ask.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: The
typical question.
We don't speak about road maps,
but what about your road map?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Is there any new
things on the horizon
that you can share with
the audience about what
they can expect from IoT Core?
INDRANIL CHAKRABORTY: So
again, we can't really
speak to our road map.
But one thing I
can guarantee is,
we see the value in IoT Core,
and how customers and partners
and developers can
use this to build
really compelling applications
around smart cities, and oil
and gas, and manufacturing.
So a couple of key-- let
me at a high level talk
about three things which
really we are looking into.
One is, we do want
to make it really
simple for both developers
and our partners
to build applications on Google
platforms, specifically on IoT.
So that's still our
basic principle,
and we want to
continue doing that.
So you would see
a lot of features
around how can you
quickly jumpstart
your journey with IoT on the
UI side, on the API side?
We started with the
managed service,
we started with the
MQTT, but we want
to make it even more simpler
so your overall onboarding
experience can become
really frictionless for you
to get started with any
device in any sort of hardware
you want to do.
So that's one area where we
want to continue investing,
and we will invest more.
And you will see
some feature releases
in subsequent couple of months.
The second area really
is our partner ecosystem
is pretty strong.
We have a good number of
hardware partners around--
think about Intel, NXP,
Microchip, Marvell, Sierra
Wireless.
All these IoT device and
hardware partners have agreed,
and they've built simple
libraries so that you can,
once you buy those devices as a
developer from these partners,
you can easily and seamlessly
connect to Cloud IoT Core
and start building applications.
So we're going to continue
to build out our partner
ecosystem more
than the device set
as well as on the
application side.
So for developers, it
makes it even simpler
for them to build and
end to end application.
Third area is, as
I mentioned, we do
have a pretty rich set
of services for data
analytics, time series
analysis, machine learning.
And what we want to do is
make it even more simpler
and more integrated to
our overall Google IoT
Core and the rest
of our IoT platform
so that developers
can really start
using it without
needing to write
hundreds of lines of code.
So I think those are the three
areas where you would see us
investing more in near future.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Gabe, I'll direct this to you.
If people want to learn
more about IoT Core,
learn how to get set up
and how to get going,
where should they go?
GABE WEISS:
cloud.google.com/iot-core.
MARK MANDEL: That's it?
GABE WEISS: That's it.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
GABE WEISS: Yeah, so
there's a beta page.
You can view all
the docs from there.
There's a bunch of quickstart
guides and examples
already up in a couple
different languages.
So everything should
be there to get you
up and on your
feet really quick.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And for those people
that are lazy like
me and like videos,
the talk that you gave
in Barcelona recently,
was that recorded?
GABE WEISS: It was not.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Is there any video
that we might want to check out?
GABE WEISS: Not yet,
but I'm planning
on recording some soon.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
All right, cool.
Well, if anything comes
up in the meantime,
we'll put it in the show notes.
Before we wrap up today, we like
to give everyone a last chance.
Is there anything that you
want to mention or plug,
or any events coming up
or anything like that
that you want to make sure
that our listeners know
about in case we have missed
it on this episode so far?
INDRANIL CHAKRABORTY:
I would just
say that we are very excited
with this beta release
for Cloud IoT Core.
We're seeing a tremendous
amount of interest and traction.
And we're really excited,
and we're really happy
that we have released
this product,
and so developers and
partners can really
build compelling application.
You know, our goal,
really, next step
is to get this to GA so that
developers and customers can
really think about
production deployment,
and get a peace of
mind with SLA as well.
So very excited.
And I think in terms of
the developer conference,
I'll let Gabe speak to it.
Yeah.
From our perspective,
like Indranil said,
making sure that we make it to
GA is our priority right now.
So I know early in 2018 we've
got a couple of conferences
coming up where we're going
to be really diving deep,
getting people on board
with it, and exploring more.
But nothing specific in
the super near future.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
Well, looking forward to that.
And thank you so much,
both Indranil and Gabe,
for taking the time
today to talk about IoT.
INDRANIL CHAKRABORTY: Thank you.
GABE WEISS: Yeah,
thanks for having us.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thanks again
to both Indranil and Gabe
for telling us a little bit
more about what IoT Core is
and what people can
built on top of it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, it's
a really cool platform.
And if you're interested at
all, the next episode that
is coming up, we are
talking to a customer
who is using it in production.
And they have a
really, really, really
cool use case that I think
is quite interesting.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
super interesting interview.
So looking forward to that.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
All right, well, why
don't we get stuck
into the question of the week?
So I figure we normally
talk about GCP.
But in this instance,
Francesc, you
posted up a really
interesting blog post.
I read it a lot.
I found it quite fascinating.
You're leaving Google.
What about me?
What am I going
to do without you?
What's going on here?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Why?
Why?
MARK MANDEL: Why?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: [LAUGHS]
So yes, I am leaving Google.
I wrote that little blog post
that went a little bit viral,
and I've got a lot of
people asking me whether I'm
moving to Microsoft or Heptio.
I'm not moving to Microsoft,
I'm not moving to Heptio.
I'm joining a tiny, tiny
startup that I will be
talking more about it later on.
But I would be still
doing a lot of Go.
I will be still going to
all of the Go conferences.
So if people want
to see me there,
I will still be
there, so don't worry.
doing Just For Func.
The only thing I will not be
doing is talking to you, Mark,
on this beautiful,
beautiful podcast.
And it is not because I really
want to stop talking to you,
which, partly, you know, maybe.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
I know you do.
You do.
It's fine.
I understand.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It is just
because I am very excited.
New experience, new opportunity,
so I could not say no.
MARK MANDEL: That's
totally fair enough.
So who do we have replacing you?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I am
very excited about this.
And I say all the time in this
podcast that I am very excited,
but I am sincerely excited
about this because I--
so I think it was episode 93?
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Correct me if I'm wrong.
Episode 93.
We had an episode on the
difference between AI
and machine learning.
And basically, all
of this came up
because we were having a lunch
conversation with Melanie
Warrick.
And as I'm sure everybody
noticed, she's super cool.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So we decided that, since she's
so cool and so interesting,
and also pretty good
at doing podcasts,
that maybe she'd be
interested in replacing me.
So we asked her,
and she said yes.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, Melanie.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
so super excited.
And I'm super excited to
introduce Melanie Warrick.
Melanie, how are you doing?
MELANIE: I'm good, thank you.
I'm really looking forward
to taking over, taking all
the things and destroying Mark.
No.
[LAUGHS] I'm looking forward
to working with Mark.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes, yes.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: So the tradition
on this podcast stays
exactly the same.
It's fine.
[LAUGHTER]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MELANIE: That's right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's
one guest against Mark.
The guest changes.
The host changes, but that's OK.
It's still against mark.
Perfect.
MELANIE: That's the game.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
No, that's fine.
Melanie, if people didn't
manage to catch your episode 93,
you should totally listen to it.
Do you want to tell the audience
a little bit about yourself?
MELANIE: Yes.
I am basically senior developer
advocate over at Google,
and working on Google
Cloud Platform,
working on AI and
machine learning.
And before that I
worked at change.org
doing machine learning
in production,
as well as worked at a startup
building out an open source
neural net platform in Java
that was not TensorFlow.
So those are my kind
of tracks to get down
the path into software
engineering and data science.
But yeah, I'm looking
forward to this.
This will be fun.
Mark, you'll have a little
bit of a different experience
with me for sure, but I
think we can find some fun
topics to dive into.
MARK MANDEL: I
look forward to it.
I've worked with Francesc
for now two years.
It's fine.
Yeah, we need change.
MELANIE: It's time to move on.
No.
MARK MANDEL: It's fine.
It's fine.
No, not at all.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's been
100, 101 episodes of Francesc
all the time.
MELANIE: It's a lot of time.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I think
it's time to change, isn't it?
[LAUGHS]
MELANIE: It takes more than 24
hours to listen to all that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, yes.
MARK MANDEL: Oh my God, yeah.
That's terrifying now
that I think about it.
MELANIE: I know, right?
It's a lot of time.
Francesc, though, you're
going to be missed.
And hopefully we'll
get a chance to get you
back and come visit and tell
us about all the things.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
You know, I would
be very happy to come
back as a guest anytime,
especially I've heard that the
San Francisco office is still
serving really good free lunch.
So we can always organize it.
There's absolutely
nothing wrong with me.
MELANIE: Free lunch is
very valuable, especially
when you're working
for a startup.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
[LAUGHS]
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
Oh, Francesc, thank you to you
for, oh man, 101 episodes of us
doing this together.
It has been a delight
and a pleasure.
You are definitely
going to be missed.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thank you so much.
It was indeed an
amazing experience.
101 episodes, and
we've interviewed
people like, I don't know,
Vint Cerf, John Wilkes.
You know, basically all of my
big heroes of computer science
have been there.
We have not interviewed
all of them yet,
so it's hopefully up
to you and Melanie
to convince them, and go get
every single one of them.
Notably, I know that Melanie
is into AI and stuff.
And I'd love to
have an episode--
I'm going to ask this
as a departure present.
I want, as a gift, an
interview with Fefe Lee.
MELANIE: Nice.
I am a fan of Fefe Lees as well.
So I like that you're
making a request on your way
out the door.
Is this like my last wish?
[LAUGHS]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: My last wish
is an episode with Fefe Lee.
Not myself as a host, but I
will definitely listen to it.
MELANIE: That's fair.
That's totally fair.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But yeah.
But thank you.
Thank you, Mark, for
really, really fun times.
Long times.
101 episodes with around
30 to 45 minutes each.
That's a long time
of us speaking.
But still, it was awesome.
And looking forward to
the 100 next episodes
and seeing what you and
Melanie are able to build.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, Francesc,
for the last time,
thank you so much for joining
me on this episode this week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank
you, Mark and Melanie,
for joining me in
this episode today.
And thank you all for listening.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
And we'll see you all next week.
MELANIE: Have a good one.
[MUSIC PLAYING]